roland dumas relaxé en appel dans
l'affairé elf qui avait entraîné sa
chute c'est un nouveau coup de semonce
pour la justice financière
christine deviers-joncour loïk le floch
prigent et alfred sirvin sont condamnées
respectivement à dix-huit mois deux ans
et demi et trois ans de prison ferme
le coup d'accélérateur de washington
dans la crise irakienne george bush
s'engage à présenter le 5 février
mercredi prochain des preuves de
l'armement irakiens et des liens avec al
qaïda quinze mille réserviste à
supplémentaires ont été rappelés par
washington
la révolte de l'école face à la violence
fait tache d'huile dans le jura un
enseignant a été giflé par un parent
d'élève une plainte est déposée près de
dieppe un nouveau lycée est en grève
grève qui se poursuit également à
goussainville pourtant considérée comme
l établissement pilote trois questions
ce soir à stéphanie fuentes professeur
d'espagnol
bonsoir à tout à l'heure et merci d'être
avec nous vraiment ce soir
faut-il alléger l'impôt sur la fortune
le gouvernement décide de s'attaquer à
cette réforme ultrasensible au nom de
l'emploi dit-il
la gauche dénonce un cadeau fait aux
plus riches enfin le baby-boom continue
796 1000 naissances l'an passé la france
reste championne d'europe de la
fécondité juste après l'irlande
bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
avant de développer ces titres ce
bulletin d' alerte de météo france
attention à la neige dès la nuit
prochaine si vous habitez dans l'un de
ses 58 départements
une grosse moitié de la france on attend
des chutes de neige d'une ampleur
inégalée depuis des années indique les
prévisionnistes prenez vos précautions
donc la société des autoroutes du sud de
la france conseil de différer les
déplacements le centre d'informations
routières d'île de france appelle
également à la vigilance d'autres
précisions avec isabelle martinet après
ce journal et puis nous reviendrons sur
cette très brusque chute des
températures dans quelques instants la
justice donc avec cet ultime coup de
théâtre dans l' affaire elf l'ancien
ministre des affaires étrangères roland
dumas a donc été relaxé tout à l'heure
par la cour d'appel après cinq ans
d'instruction et plusieurs semaines de
prison la cour a finalement estimé que
son attitude pouvait être considérée
comme moralement blâme
bhl mais pas pénalement répréhensible
olivier caroff edouard perrin yves
jacques silencieux innocent roland dumas
ressort du palais de justice totalement
blanchi les juges ont choisi la relaxe
là où l'accusation ne réclamaient qu'une
peine symbolique
la cour d'appel a écarté toutes les
charges contre l'ancien ministre
même les plus emblématiques du dossier
elle retient la bonne foi de roland
dumas en ce qui concerne les les
fameuses bodies et les statuettes avant
les cadeaux faits par christine
deviers-joncour avec l'argent d'elf pour
elle la cour demande de la prison 18
mois ferme
encore une fois selon que vous êtes
puissant ou misérable voile à l'issue de
ce procès c'est dany trois ans ferme
également pour alfred sirvin seul détenu
du dossier elle
il restera en prison son ancien patron
loïk le floch prigent risque de l'y
rejoindre très vite
absent à l'audience pour raisons de
santé il est désormais sous le coup d'un
mandat d'arrêt pour la justice c'est
donc définitif il n'y a pas eu
d'affaires dumas seulement une petite
affaire elf
le dossier principal lui sera jugé en
mars oui il s'agit d'une des affaires
politico financières les plus
médiatiques les plus retentissantes de
ces dernières années pour la justice
financière c'est donc une nouvelle gifle
dominique verdeilhan virgili anneaux une
simple porte qui sou
ainsi commence l'une des affaires
judiciaires les plus médiatiques une
seule image de juge un ancien ministre
une perquisition c'était il ya cinq ans
presque jour pour jour la sphère elle
devient la sphère du marque une carrière
d'avocat pour défendre les autres et les
grandes causes
mais en 83 françois mitterrand lui donne
un portefeuille affaires européennes
puis affaires étrangères en 95
il accède au rang de cinquième
personnage de l'état président du
conseil constitutionnel un poste dont il
est obligé de démissionner en mars 2000
car en changeant d'avocats à son ex
maîtresse christine deviers-joncour
change de discours
elle charge roland dumas les bottes
l'appartement rue de lille les
statuettes
c'est lg qui a payé dit elle et l'ancien
ministre ne l'ignorent pas le procureur
de la république de l'époque dénonce les
mensonges et les contre-vérités de
roland dumas en mars 2001 il est
condamné à six mois de prison ferme pour
le tribunal il a franchi les limites de
la loi pénale j'imagine que votre
position est plus confortable
en tant qu'avocat que dans le box il
faut pas mélanger les genres en octobre
dernier roland dumas est exclu pour deux
ans du ps eva joly elle a rejoint la
norvège sans état d'âme
je pense que parfois j'ai mal estimé
l'importance de chaque protagoniste et
dossier mais je ne pense pas m'être
beaucoup beaucoup coûté
un simple blâme voilà ce que décerne en
fin de course les juges à roland dumas
après celle des dossiers strauss kahn
robert hue et de la société générale
cette relaxe pourrait sonner comme une
nouvelle condamnation du pôle financier
et parmi les réactions à noter celle du
député socialiste arnaud montebourg qui
avait demandé l'un des premiers et
démission de roland dumas du conseil
constitutionnel
les citoyens ne peuvent plus avoir
confiance en la justice dit il une
justice à deux vitesses calme précaire
aujourd'hui en côte d'ivoire on évoquera
la situation politique dans un instant
d'abord l'inquiétude des seize mille
ressortissants français pas de
manifestations violentes pas d'émeute
aujourd'hui mais les évacuations ont
commencé
250 personnes ont été rapatriées
essentiellement des femmes et des
enfants il s'agit de familles de
salariés de grandes entreprises qui
opèrent sur place envoyés spéciaux à
abidjan eric monier frédéric ranque pour
la plupart d'entre eux la décision fut
déchirante et le temps de réflexion très
court moins de 24 heures êtes vous prêt
à quitter la côte d'ivoire
oui ou non
ce matin 250 personnes personnels
expatriés et leurs familles ont répondu
par l'affirmative à leurs sociétés
filiales de grandes entreprises
françaises qui organisait sous la
protection des forces de l'ordre
ivoiriennes
un départ de côte d'ivoire
pour la cif comme premier groupe agro
alimentaire en afrique de l'ouest
ils étaient une soixantaine à traverser
en silence abidjan cette ville qu'ils
habitent depuis des décennies parfois
alors bien sûr rien n'est facile
angoisse la peur ressentie lors des
manifestations anti françaises de ces
derniers jours mais le moral n'y était
pas avant de monter dans un avion
spécialement affrété
bien peu ont accepté de répondre à nos
questions par pudeur sans doute
et quand ils l'ont fait c'était toujours
pour dire qu'il reviendrait j'ai vécu
tous les coups d'état et les différentes
manifestations qui ont eu lieu
là je pense que la situation est un peu
plus difficile et plus tendue que
d'habitude on là j'ai pensé qu'il valait
mieux que je m'en aille pour quelques
jours quand on est optimiste mais on
espère que ce n'est que provisoire si on
est pessimiste on dit on tire une croix
sur le pays
je crois qu'il ne faut aller ni dans un
sens ni dans l'autre
aujourd'hui il faut il faut garder les
pieds sur terre et puis se laisser
guider un petit peu par les événements
il ne s'agit encore que de départ au
compte gouttes
le gouvernement français rappelle
d'ailleurs que rapatriement de ses
ressortissants de côte d'ivoire n'est
pas d'actualité mais un plan est prêt au
kazoo il s'agirait alors d'une opération
de grande ampleur puisqu'il faudrait
évacuer 16000 français et 30 mille
étrangers placés sous la protection des
soldats france et en ce qui concerne la
situation politique maintenant l'accord
de marcoussis menace de voler en éclats
cet après-midi les partis ivoiriens
majoritaire au parlement ont rejeté
l'attribution des ministères de la
défense et l'intérieur aux rebelles
l'armée vous le savez s'étaient déjà
prononcés en ce sens tout en fait est
suspendu à l'allocution du président
laurent gbagbo
et on a appris il ya une heure qu'elle
n'était finalement attendu qu'en fin de
semaine la crise irakienne après le
rapport mitigé des inspecteurs george
bush veut donc reprendre la main il
promet des preuves contre bagdad
ça n'est pas la première fois mais la
nouveauté aujourd'hui c'est que la
maison blanche a fixé une date pour les
livres et le 5 février c'est à dire dans
une semaine exactement à washington
etienne leenhardt
ça une opinion publique pas franchement
certaine qu'une guerre en irak
aujourd'hui est nécessaire le président
américain n'a pas ménagé sa peine hier
soir pour diaboliser saddam hussein dans
les grandes lignes l'irak caches d armes
aux inspecteurs l'irak a des liens avec
al qaïda et oussama ben laden et le
régime en place est l'incarnation du mal
pour l'épreuve il faudra attendre
mercredi prochain ça que c'est le
secrétaire d'état colin powell
présentera aux nations unies des
informations provenant de nos services
de renseignements sur les programmes
dits légaux d'armement de l'irak et ses
tentatives pour cacher ses armes aux
inspecteurs et ses liens avec des
groupes terroristes
il a donc pour coline powell l'immense
responsabilité d'apporter aux nations
unies est donc au monde la preuve que
l'irak continue de tricher on se
souvient qu'en 1962 les états unis de
john kennedy avait rendu publiques des
photos prouvant que l'union soviétique
d'alors préparer à cuba l'installation
de missiles pointés vers le territoire
américain
quarante ans plus tard les images des
satellites celle ci montre par exemple
un palais de saddam hussein à bagdad
peuvent détecter le moindre mouvement de
trous on ne connaîtra que dans une
semaine la nature des preuves américaine
mail intime conviction du principal
accusateur sembles elle bien établi
aucune sorte
nous consulterons nos alliés at mais
qu'il n'y ait pas de malentendu si
saddam hussein se ne désarme pas
totalement
nous mènerons une coalition pour le
désarment chaîne dès janvier un
président déterminé cent cinquante mille
soldats en route pour la région de ce
côté ci de l'atlantique
plus personne ne voit très bien comment
un conflit pourrait être évité
le président américain recevra demain
l'italien berlusconi puis vendredi
l'anglais tony blair pour ce qui est
d'ores et déjà présenté par la presse
américaine comme un véritable conseil de
guerre oui de réaction d'ores et déjà la
france se réjouit de la prochaine
diffusion de ces informations nous le
demandons depuis des semaines
indique-t-on au quai d'orsay
tandis que bagdad estime que le discours
de george bush est un vieux disque rayé
et promet une leçon sévère aux états
unis en cas d' attaque pour reprendre
très précisément les termes employés de
toute évidence les événements sont en
train de s'accélérer à ce jour 87 mille
soldats américains sont déployés dans la
région dont 35 milles au koweït à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres de la
frontière irakienne l'armée a recréé une
ville pour s'entraîner à la guerre
urbaine envoyés spéciaux claude sans
père patrick démunis c'est un exercice
classique il faut apprendre à rentrer
dans une habitation et demi en toute
sécurité pièce par pièce en évitant les
pièges
ces soldats américains appartiennent au
3ème bataillon d'infanterie
nous sommes quelque part dans le désert
au nord du koweït la frontière irakienne
est à moins de 15 km ici pas de radio
pas de télé président bush ou au sto le
président bush a fait un grand discours
il ya vous êtes au courant
n'ont ils rien absolument rien il faut
que le commandant se renseigne et nous
disent vous personnellement vous
voudriez ventre et les maisons où elles
en irak
ah c'est vraiment une question difficile
toute la journée il multiplie les
exercices
il s'agit de monter le plus vite
possible sur un char ces hommes sont
depuis plus de quatre mois
ce qui frappe c'est leur détermination
trente secondes les gars 18 16 points
s'il faut faire la guerre est bien
longue
le plus tôt possible sera le mieux à 3
si nous rentrons quatre mois dans le
désert
-selon certains tue le temps comme ils
peuvent
en attendant l'ordre d'une éventuelle
offensive pour le moment personne ne
peut dire exactement combien de temps
vont durer ces manoeuvres d'entraînement
cohen à l'heure actuelle il ya près de
quinze mille soldats américains ici dans
ce dlc que nous avons rencontrés
aujourd'hui en tout cas nous on se
faisait guère d'illusions sur la suite
en france la suite du procès de
christine malèvre qui est vraiment
l'infirmière anxieuse fragiles ou
perverse les psychiatres ont défilé à la
barre aujourd'hui comme souvent il ya
autant d'avis que d'experts mais tous se
retrouvent sur un point christine
malèvre n'a rien d'une faune stéphane
breitner virgili à dos une femme
perverse pour les uns une personnalité
bouleversé par la souffrance de ces
malades pour les autres les experts qui
se sont succédé à la barre ont montré
leurs divisions sur le cas de christine
malet pour une partie des psychiatres
elle se sentait toute puissante sur
investi dans son métier d'aide-soignante
pour les autres
l'infirmière n'est pas une tueuse c'est
plutôt une hyper sensible qui voulait
soulager la souffrance des autres
je ne pense pas que ceci va lèvres serez
aujourd'hui dangereuse est ce que je me
suis permis de dire à la cour de façon
provocatrice c'est qu'aujourd'hui si
elle était infirmière ce qu'elle est pas
son destin ce n'est pas ce qu'elle a
choisi
je ne pense pas que elle referait ce
qu'elle a fait les parties civiles elles
n'ont pas montré autant de différence
sur la personnalité de l'accusé
je trouve au contraire qu'elle est
redoutable dans la manière dont elle ne
veut pas passer aux aveux
à savoir qu'elle s'est fixé une ligne de
défense qu'elle n'en démord pas ce soir
les débats sont terminées demain
christine malèvre écoutera les
réquisitions de l'avocat général
elle encourt la prison à perpétuité
justice toujours soupçon excessif ou
pratique organisée on assiste en ce
moment à une multiplication des affaires
de mariages blancs présumée à corbeil
essonnes près de paris et le maire serge
dassault refuse malgré une décision en
référé de célébrer l'union de l'une de
ses administrés avec un ressortissant
tunisien en situation irrégulière il
invoque notamment une différence d'âge
jugée suspecte la mariée à 52 ans son
futur conjoint 25 ans gilles marine et
thierry breton à partir du 14 août
c'est ce qu'on avait dit fin d'été il
est il était clairement en séjour
irrégulier
lorsque le maire de corbeil-essonnes
apprend à la fin de l'été dernier qu'un
tunisien de 25 ans sans carte de séjour
désir épousé une française âgée elle de
52 ans sur le pignon très vite fait il
s'agit d'un faux mariage et zoé
ce garçon est arrivé au mois de juillet
il acquiesce et pas avant oui
débarqué chez cette dame sans doute par
des relations et il n'avait plus de
visas à partir de 2 août septembre
mais c'est sur lui à peine de mort il ya
des tas de mariage blanc par les blancs
c'est pas marianne bleus combinent pour
obtenir quelque chose
en général ces français le 22 janvier la
justice a ordonné à serge dassault de
procéder rapidement au mariage peine
perdue le maire a fait appel et
maintient son refus attitude illégale
selon l'avocat du coup droit au mariage
et en droit absolu
qui est reconnue à toute personne sur le
sol français qu'elle soit la nationalité
française de nationalité étrangère
pourvus ou pas d'un titre de séjour
quels que soient leur ultime conviction
les maires ne peuvent s'opposer à un
mariage certains voudraient pourtant
obliger les futurs époux à être en
situation régulière en 1993 un projet de
loi similaire avait été rejetée par le
conseil constitutionnel
même cas de figure en tout cas à orléans
où la mairie refuse également des
mariages jugés suspects le garde des
sceaux dominique perben s'est saisi de
la faire il s'est prononcé tout à
l'heure pour la prolongation de la durée
des enquêtes actuellement le délai est
limitée à un mois le ministre estime que
des réseaux organisés sont en place
cela dit les apparences sont parfois
trompeuses ainsi à chanteloup les vignes
nous avons retrouvé un couple marié il
ya un an malgré l'opposition du maire
reportage julie benzoni françois-xavier
gutton depuis cet après-midi samira et
olivier laurie savoure les petites
choses de la vie
un an de mariage et autant de batailles
judiciaires
aujourd'hui la justice a reconnu que
leur union n'était pas un mariage blanc
oui on sait dans le foot je me batte
maintenant coûte à la gauche pour se
faire respecter
c'est quand même trop tôt en janvier
2002 le maire de chanteloup les vignes
ne veut pas marié olivier samira il
soupçonne un mariage de complaisance lui
est français elle marocaine en situation
irrégulière
le procureur donne raison aux mariés la
cérémonie a lieu mais dès le lendemain
le maire fait appel un an plus tard il
est à nouveau condamné et doit verser un
euro symbolique de dommages et intérêts
en tant qu'épouse samir alors y obtient
donc une carte de séjour d'un an
fini les soupçons elle se concentre
maintenant sur la couleur de la layette
du petit pages seulement font parce que
j'ai trop vu le marais et hier pour moi
et j'ai envie de faire un enfant quand
les mamans
c'est le moment ce sera un garçon
arrivée prévue début du mois d'avril la
violence à l'école le désarroi où la
révolte des établissements est
apparemment en train de faire tache
d'huile deux nouveaux cas aujourd'hui
d'abord à crotenay dans le jura un
professeur a été giflé par un parent
d'élève parce qu'ils avaient confisqué
le portable de son fils pendant le cours
l'inspecteur d'académie a porté plainte
et puis à envermeu près de rouen les
enseignants ont cessé les cours car là
encore un élève exclu a été réintégrée
eléonore gay désavoué par leur
hiérarchie
ces enseignants seront en grève demain
il conteste la réintégration d'un élève
exclu du lycée en décembre dernier une
enquête de gendarmerie avait alors
conduit à plusieurs interpellations
parmi les élèves
deux d'entre eux soupçonnés de détention
de cannabis sont exclues par le conseil
de discipline vous après avoir fait
appel
un lycéen vient d'obtenir le sursis ce
jeune a tout de même été interpellé avec
plus de 21 grammes et 21 grammes ne peut
pas être ne peuvent pas être destiné à
une consommation personnelle
selon les professeurs l'impunité de
l'élève va à l'encontre des principes
éducatifs qu'ils défendent mais
l'inspecteur d'académie a choisi de
faire preuve de clémence en raison des
difficultés du lycéen
c'est un jeune qui réussit bien qu'issue
bien engagé non dans ses études mais
c'est un jeune qui rencontrent des
difficultés sociales et personnelles
extrêmement importante il a un suivi
éducatif qui justement doit être pris en
considération les enseignants sont
censés se soumettre à la décision de la
commission d'appel
mais en raison de la polémique l'élève
n'a pu reprendre les cours comme prévu
lundi dernier et statues cours pendant
ce temps à goussainville où les cours
sont suspendus je vous le rappelle
depuis une semaine maintenant et on va
s'arrêter un instant sur ce cas très
particulier pourquoi parce qu'il s'agit
d'un établissement considéré comme
pilote contre la violence et pourtant
les agressions continues elles sont
régulières alors expliquez nous votre
exaspération stéphanie fuentes vous êtes
professeur d'espagnol et vous dites on
ne demande pas plus de moyens
qu'est-ce que cela signifie oui bonsoir
et bien il me semble que c'est clair
depuis maintenant une semaine et 2
lycée a déclenché la procédure d' alerte
donc le personnel est en retrait afin de
laisser le champ libre à nos supérieurs
pour rétablir la sécurité
la différence d'autres lycées qui
demande à être classé en zone sensible
est fait prévention violence nous nous
avons déjà tout cet attirail là ainsi
que les caméras et les grillages et
pourtant nous constatons une une
escalade de la violence assez
impressionnante qui va tout simplement
du racket au passage à tabac d'un
surveillant à plusieurs reprises de
menaces verbales menaces de mort je
pense que la leur
nous pensons que la sécurité doit être
réinstaurée au plus vite mais donc vous
dites nous avons tous les moyens dont on
parle beaucoup en ce moment
oui ces moyens matériels caméra vous en
vous avez les les postes aussi de deux
surveillants
oui même si c'est évidemment ce n'est
jamais assez mais oui nous sommes alors
décidément on n'a pas de chance avec
stephen il faut une thèse parce que hier
déjà on a eu un souci matériel pour
relater donc de cette cessation des
cours qui dure depuis une semaine
maintenant à goussainville
là encore on a un petit souci de
faisceaux est ce qu'on va arriver à le
rétablir
apparemment non nous attendons quelques
secondes ça sera peut-être pour plus
tard
la sécurité sur les routes en attendant
images d'abord d'un procès inhabituel
aux assises de chalon sur saône
ce routier cgt est jugé pour avoir lancé
une antenne radio sur un chauffeur
allemand qui tentaient de forcer un
barrage lors de la grève de 96 lequel
chauffeur souffre désormais d'un
handicap à 80% énorme manifestation de
soutien à l'accusée dans les rues
aujourd'hui entre deux et quatre mille
personnes selon les sources ont défilé
pour réclamer son acquittement autres
routiers met à l'honneur cette fois il
s'agit de nicolas laberthonnière ce
chauffeur de 35 ans qui avait eu la
présence d'esprit d'arrêter son camion
en travers de l'autoroute pour sauver
une fillette tombée sur la voie
il a été décoré de l'ordre du mérite
aujourd'hui alban nicosie françois
jullien pieds noirs
nicollin laberthonnière au nom du
président de la république nous faisons
chevalier de l'ordre national du mérite
pour nicolas se tue donc une matinée
chargée d'émotion la reconnaissance
officielle de la république bien sûr
mais aussi des retrouvailles avec cette
famille allemande dont il a embelli de
destin en sauvant la vie de la petite
léna aujourd'hui âgée de quatre ans deux
familles qui ont décidé de se revoir
désormais plus souvent vous venir en
vacances cet été chez nous
maintenant c'est des amis encore on a
fait abstraction de ce qui est arrivé le
8 août dernier sur l'autoroute près de
montélimar
lena jouait à l'arrière avec la porte de
la voiture brusquement elle tomba sur la
chaussée immédiatement nicolas réussi à
stopper son camion et protège à l'enfant
jusqu'à l'arrivée des secours
lennar ne fut que légèrement blessé six
mois plus tard elle va tout à fait bien
mais sa maman est toujours bouleversée
pour moi nicolas est un ange gardien il
a si bien su réagir
la cérémonie de ce matin visait aussi à
valoriser la conduite responsable
les deux familles s'y sont prêtés de
bonne grâce tandis que les enfants
avaient déjà une autre priorité ouvrir
de nouveaux cadeaux l'actualité sociale
d'abord sachez que vous ne trouverez pas
vos quotidiens nationaux dans les
kiosques demain la cgt des nouvelles
messageries de la presse parisienne est
en grève contre une restructuration du
secteur pharisiens l'avenir d'air lib et
de ses 3200 salariés s'assombrit un peu
plus dernier rebondissement aujourd'hui
l'investisseur néerlandais imca renonce
à reprendre la compagnie il dénonce
l'attitude égoïste d'une minorité du
personnel et notamment des pilotes face
au plan d'économies qu'il demandait avec
entre autres des importantes réductions
de salaires la direction espère que
cette décision n'est pas définitive la
cgt elle réaffirme que le plan de
rigueur proposé n'est pas acceptable en
l'état
et c'est décidément la série noire en
matière sociale danone annonce
aujourd'hui que ses usines lui de ris
orangis et de calais fermeront un an
plus tôt que prévu en mars prochain
en ce qui concerne metaleurop maintenant
à noter l'intervention de jacques chirac
lui-même en visite à nantes il a eu des
mots très durs contre les dirigeants du
groupe enl écoute dans le drame que
connaissent aujourd'hui les salariés de
metaleurop leurs droits les plus
fondamentaux ont été bafoués
si on regarde les instructions
judiciaires en cours
cela ça cela s'avère nécessaire je
demanderai au gouvernement de proposer
des dispositions législatives pour que
des agissement aussi scandaleux ne
demeure pas impuni
oui depuis plusieurs jours le
gouvernement veut mon
très qu'il n'est pas inactif sur ce
dossier lors de ce comité
interministériel à matignon aujourd'hui
sur les plans sociaux jean-pierre
raffarin a insisté notamment sur les
contrats de reconversion qui seront
proposés dans les bassins d'emploi les
plus touchés par les fermetures d usines
on a aussi appris qu'une enquête
préliminaire avait été ouverte dans la
sphère metaleurop jean pierre raffarin
qui s'attaque au même moment un dossier
très sensible politiquement celui de
l'impôt sur la fortune rappelons d'abord
ces quelques chiffres
128 mille ménages étaient assujettis à l
isf en 1989 lorsqu'il a été rétablie ils
sont aujourd'hui deux fois plus nombreux
271 mille ménages pour une recette
totale de deux milliards quatre cent
soixante millions d'euros soit près de
17 milliards de francs a depuis
plusieurs mois des députés de la
majorité réclament une réforme
il estime que l'impôt sur la fortune est
contre productif parce qu'il pousserait
des créateurs ou des propriétaires
d'entreprises à s'installer à l'étranger
alors la justice sociale est elle en
l'occurrence l'ennemi de l'efficacité
économique dossier signé martin gouès
m'a dit dis ouah pour profiter de son
argent faut-il rester en france bon
accueil elle a choisi patron d'une
chaîne de distribution dans le nord le
siège social de son entreprise est en
france personnellement il habite de
l'autre côté de la frontière
selon lui ils paient trop d'impôts et un
de trop l'impôt sur la fortune
comparables vous avez l'entreprise qui
vaut 100 millions d'euros tous les ans
il faut payer 2 5 millions d'euros
mais pour avoir 2 5 millions d'euros
dans votre poche
il faut sortir cinq millions parce que
vous devez payer vos armes aux personnes
à l'avant en 15 ans de temps vous avez
donné la valeur totale de l'entreprise
ce que les étrangers n'ont pas à payer
comme lui ils seraient chaque année
entre 200 et 300 patron a quitté la
france
le manque à gagner pour les caisses de
l'état près de 20 millions d'euros 1 %
de ce que rapporte e lles un impôt que
l'on paie dès que l'on possède sept cent
vingt mille euros 4 millions 700 mille
francs
aujourd'hui un patron ne paie pas lier
sf s'il détient 25% de son entreprise
le projet serait d'étendre une partie de
cette exonération aux membres de sa
famille qui détiennent aussi du capital
même s'ils ne travaillent pas dans la
société
les gagnants seront souvent les membres
d'une famille qui possède des actions de
l'entreprise sans être eux-mêmes les
dirigeants d'entreprises attendus par
les patrons cette réforme secoue le
monde politique le premier ministre se
défend de faire un cadeau fiscal aux
entreprises
je suis favorable à tous les allègements
fiscaux et sociaux qui permettent à
l'argent non pas de dormir car celle ci
doit être taxé mais au contraire de
travailler pour l'emploi pour
l'investissement et pour les entreprises
à l'heure de la multiplication des plans
sociaux pour la gauche le gouvernement a
choisi son camp
monsieur raffarin il ya de la compassion
pour les licenciés et il a de la
générosité pour les grandes fortunes et
ceux qui investissent dans des oeuvres
d'art sont toujours exonérés de l'impôt
sur la fortune
voilà nous retrouvons maintenant c'est
fanny fuentes professeur d'espagnol à
goussainville donc un lycée où les cours
ont cessé depuis une semaine on le
disait stéphanie fuentes puisque le
faisceau est maintenant rétabli ce lycée
il a tout tout ce qu'on évoque
aujourd'hui pour lutter contre la
violence les postes de surveillant les
caméras les portails et pourtant donc
cette insécurité continue elle est très
forte
vous évoquez les tentatives de racket
des crachats des intimidations de qui
s'agit-il des élèves ou de personnes
venues de l'extérieur
non il ne s'agit pas essentiellement
d'élèves il s'agit essentiellement d'un
intrus qui viennent donc dans le lycée à
coups de 30 40 pour pour ce livre est
donc sûre sur ce terrain de bataille qui
le leur finalement assez
c'est à ces exactions alors là on a
envie de dire c'est plus le terrain de
la police ou de la justice
qu'en est il ça ça n'est pas à nous de
juger il me semble que celui qui doit
juger et trancher pour ramener la
sécurité c'est notre ministre par
exemple monsieur darcos
parce que d'abord si son devoir et puis
c'est sa fonction et si je suis navré de
le dire il n'est pas capable très
rapidement de ramener la sécurité et
bien alors c'est à lui de changer le
métier en tout cas ça n'est pas à nous
est infirmière surveillante professeurs
personnels de 2,2 d'entretien de
trancher sur ce sur ce fusée de là sur
ce sujet là ce que nous voulons nous
c'est la sécurité
rapidement car nous désirons retourner
en cours très vite et vous vous dites ce
n'est pas possible actuellement de faire
court c'est impossible de faire recours
canton et ghazi à bout portant par une
bombe lacrymogène contre un collègue
surveillants se fait passer à tabac par
trois fois quand des déjections qui ont
et qui sont déjà passés devant le
tribunal et sont par exemple interdit de
séjour sur le territoire de bruxelles
ils reviennent nous narguer dans
l'établissement c'est impossible qu'ils
pourraient travailler comme ça qui est
ministre si en même temps
merci merci stéphanie fuentes pense pour
ce témoignage rappelle donc les cours
sont toujours suspendus dans ce lycée de
goussainville ce n'est pas le seul
établissement en france on évoqué
l'héritage il y a un instant une image à
l'opposé de ce qu'on vient d'entendre
une image de celle qui est devenu
aujourd'hui l'un des plus beaux parties
du monde comme on disait autrefois à
tina roussel onassis dernière
descendante de l'armateur grec onassis
elle a fêté aujourd'hui ses 18 ans elle
est donc majeur hérite d'un patrimoine
estimé à près d'un milliard de dollars
le triomphe d'ariel sharon en israël le
likoud a pratiquement doublé sa
représentation au parlement
37 députés contre 19 auparavant du
jamais vu des routes des travaillistes
19 sièges percée du parti laïc chine ou
y 15 sièges le parti religieux shass lui
obtient 11 députés
ariel sharon très largement en tête donc
mais qui n'a pas les mains libres
les tractations vont maintenant
commencer pour former une coalition sur
place charles enderlin
que faire de ce triomphe électoral dès
hier soir les dirigeants du likoud se
posait la question avec un parlement
éclater un parti travailliste a faibli
et dans l'opposition
ariel sharon aura beaucoup de mal à
former son nouveau gouvernement et dans
son discours à une heure du matin
monsieur sharon a lancé un appel à
l'union nationale
les militants protestent siffler
scandent non pas l'union nationale ariel
sharon est en porte à faux avec son
propre parti quelques minutes plus tard
il dira qu en aucun cas il ne formera de
cabinet restreint avec l'extrême droite
même si ce refus entraîne à nouveau des
élections anticipées
il voudrait à tout prix renouveler son
alliance avec la gauche
il a besoin dre mandin d'un des deux
partis modérés il a besoin d'une
légitimité internationale et je crois
que le parti travailliste peut lui
donner ça je doute je doute que le parti
travailliste puisse rentrer dans cette
coalition
en effet la présence au sein de son
gouvernement d'hommes comme shimon pérès
prix nobel de la paix donnerait une
double caution ariel sharon à son combat
contre l'intifada et à sa politique
d'implantation
alors pour les palestiniens tout cela
n'annonce rien de broc dans les ruines
de son complexe présidentiel yasser
arafat semble faire contre mauvaise
fortune bon coeur
il déclare à une chaîne israélienne
qu'il est prêt à rencontrer ariel sharon
pour discuter de paix une proposition
qui a peu de chances d'être recours un
peu plus loin dans ramallah les avis
sont unanimes la situation va encore se
détériorer
en bref images de brigitte boisselier
devant la justice américaine la
présidente de la société clonaid proches
des raéliens doit répondre de l'annnonce
de la naissance de premier bébé cloné
toujours aucune preuve à ce jour et des
scientifiques persuadé qu'il s'agit
d'une supercherie
le bébé est en israël at elle indiqué
devant le tribunal il n'a jamais été aux
états unis le grand bilan démographique
de l'année 2002 publié comme chaque
année par l'insee
première indication la france compte de
plus en plus d'habitants 61 millions à
400 mille résidents exactement soit 246
milles personnes de plus par rapport à
l'année dernière
quant à l'espérance de vie elle augmente
notamment pour les hommes 75 ans 1,6
elle reste stable chez les femmes 82,8
enfin la natalité elle se porte bien le
taux de fécondité est stable et il
s'agit là aussi d'une heureuse exception
française laetitia le genre à peine une
semaine et déjà de l'appétit coralliens
et sa soeur jumelle laurine à 6 kg de
pur bonheur font partie sans le savoir
des statistiques comme une grande
majorité des françaises
leur mère a attendu ses 30 ans pour
avoir ses enfants quand on fait des
études assez longue vie profiter d'abord
la vie travailler d'abord s'occuper de
sa carrière voyager sortir le temps
passe très vite
hop on a 30 ans et puis il faut trouver
aussi l'homme qui va avec
les françaises championnes de la
fécondité en 2002 le taux est de 1,9
enfant par femme en 94
il était de 1,7 avec 796 mais une
essence huit mille de moins qu'en 2001
la france talonne la très catholique
irlande
au hit parade de la maternité loin
devant l'allemagne l'italie ou l'espagne
elles prennent leur temps effectivement
elle accouche vers 28 30 ans voire plus
mais on a quand même plus dominante
aussi de femmes de 38 40 ans pour qui
c'est pour elles aussi leur premier
enfant
les démographes sont optimistes le
baby-boom de l'an 2000 semble vouloir se
poursuivre oui famille nombreuse famille
heureuse comme disait la chanson mais
avec quelques sacrifices tout de même
comment fait-on pour vivre et se
débrouiller à paris avec quatre enfants
reportage laurence ostolaza bernard
tissot une journée ordinaire pour cécile
c'est la corvée du mercredi ses marchés
oui marché corvée non parce que je
prends du plaisir à acheter les produits
frais pour les enfants diplômée de
l'école du louvre cécile a arrêté de
travailler voilà onze ans pour élever
ses quatre enfants
un choix de coups ni crèche ni cantine
mais une présence constante et une
cuisine maison aussi parce qu'il préfère
rentrer manger que je me suis organisé
pour les avoir le monde dit ça leur fait
une bonne coupure soit le temps d'avaler
une bouchée et il faut déjà repartir
12h50 hal gill et vous êtes sages hockey
s'est dépêché pour aller chercher
jeannesson cours de guitare vingt
minutes de trajet sportif c'est pas rien
quoi être de les accompagner d'être
présente de les écouter quand ils en ont
besoin la sortie de l'école etc
donc quand c'est fini en étant celui là
qui gênent tu viens manger toi 13h30
deuxième service pour jeunes après la
vaisselle il faut s'occuper de victor
qui prépare son examen au conservatoire
j'ai vraiment la sensation que c'est
très difficile de suivre parfaitement
son enfant en travaillant à plein temps
points jusqu'à maintenant j'ai pris mon
temps pour eux et je pense que c'est
important on verra certainement je peux
pas le dire mais une différence quoi je
pense que c'est des enfants qui sont
équilibrées
et structuré juste non mais juste pour
qu'on a montré le tempo à quarante deux
ans et s'il envisage de reprendre le
travail pour son enrichissement
personnel mais seulement à mi temps afin
de préserver l'équilibré de paul jeanne
victor et alice
la neige je vous le disais les prévu
dans 58 départements en très grande
quantité dès la nuit prochaine il y a
deux jours pourtant au baptême des
records de douceur lundi il faisait 18 à
nantes 16 en région parisienne pourquoi
ces variations brutales éléments de
réponse romuald bonnan philippe quéron
la neige tombée sur le larzac est la
région lyonnaise ces dernières heures
n'est qu'un signe avant coureur
cette nuit demain et vendredi 58
départements devraient subir le même
sort tour à tour selon météo france
d'abord le nord est et les pyrénées avec
dans certains cas plus d'un mètre de
neige
et puis le nord la normandie le bassin
parisien et le centre des chutes de
neige d'une ampleur inhabituelle
la raison cette langue de froid qui
descend de l'islande et qui fonce vers
nous décidément la météo joue au yoyo il
ya 48 heures le grand ouest jusqu'à la
région parisienne vivait cette fois des
records de douceur jamais observée par
les météorologues on va perdre
effectivement entre lundi et demain
jeudi environ une quinzaine de degrés
sur ces régions
cette chute se fait progressivement en
gros on perd environ 5 degrés chaque
jour ce qui fait sur les trois jours
donc qu à ce degré de perdus par rapport
à lundi ce qui est effectivement
beaucoup des variations extrêmes que les
spécialistes du climat considère comme
normal car très ponctuel le seul
changement évident c'est le
réchauffement 30 ans la température
moyenne a grimpé d'un demi-degré à cause
de l'activité humaine des rejets de gaz
à effet de serre par l'industrie ou les
automobiles qui modifie la composition
de l'atmosphère et donc le climat
si vous faites un changement qui va
intégrer un réchauffement s'est pas
seulement un réchauffement
c'est un changement dans le
fonctionnement de toute la circulation
de l'atmosphère le transport de l'eau
les vents et il se peut que à la
dernière moitié du 20e siècle on est
nettement plus de tempête très violente
que ce qu'on a vu depuis depuis les
premiers indices de ces changements
climatiques sont déjà visibles en europe
et en france des hivers doux avec moins
de neige et moins de gelée mais avec
beaucoup plus de plus et dans un instant
donc assure avec une attention
particulière ce soir la météo d'isabel
martinez mauvaise journée pour josé bové
la cour d'appel de montpellier a requis
cet après-midi 14 mois de prison ferme à
son encontre
le porte parole de la confédération
paysanne souhaitait éviter l'addition
des peines qu'ils encourent pour avoir
détruit des parcelles de plants
transgéniques expérimentaux délibérer le
26 février 250 militants anti ogm la
manifester leur soutien à josé bové
devant le palais de justice
les haricots verts maintenant les
haricots verts sont-ils contaminés aux
pesticides c'est en tout cas le résultat
d'une étude réalisée par le magazine que
choisir la majorité des échantillons
testés contenaient des résidus toxiques
josé dans la pierre remy possoni à
consommer sans modération précommande
les nutritionnistes certes mais à
condition de bien les laver car certains
de ces haricots essentiellement
l'importation ont montré des traces de
pesticides les traces faible mais
détecté dans 60 % des échantillons ce
qui laisse supposer une contamination de
l'ensemble des fruits et légumes y
compris dans une bonne partie de ce
produit en france
trop c'est trop que choisir visent des
pratiques agricoles douteuses on peut
trouver du white spirit de l'eau de
javel des pesticides interdits depuis
des années les années qui sont épandues
sur les champs apparemment au vu et au
su de tous ses sens que
contrôleur de l'administration y trouve
à redire jusqu'ici de l'eau de javel
comme fongicide du white spirit pour
dissoudre l'enveloppent de la plante
afin justement qu'elles absorbent mieux
le pesticide l'administration chargée du
contrôle de l'emploi des engrais se dit
soucieuse de telles pratiques qu'elle ne
semble donc pas ignorer
nous avons engagé tout un travail tout
une démarche qui vise à recenser ce type
de pratique c'est recensement montrent
que plusieurs départements français sont
touchés par un trafic de produits
phytosanitaires provenant de l'étranger
est vendu illégalement en france du
théâtre maintenant avec une pièce dédiée
au plaisir de la découverte et même de
la pensée tout court
la vie de galilée à gennevilliers c'est
une adaptation ou quasiment comique d'un
texte de brecht claude-marc sylvain doba
que sait-on de la vie de galilée quand
on est élève d'un lycée portant le nom
du célèbre astronome italien
apparemment alors une visite théâtrale
dans le laboratoire de galilée s'impose
au programme sa découverte
révolutionnaire
la terre tourne autour du soleil et non
l'inversé
durant deux mille ans l'humanité a cru
que le soleil et tous les corps célestes
tournait autour d'elle le pape les
princes les savants les cardinaux les
marchands les poissonnières et les
écoliers tous croyaient être immobile
dans cette sphère de cristal
on a voulu que le spectateur au moment
où ils regardent la pièce soit toujours
et c'est ce que nous on essaie de faire
comme acteurs soient toujours dans la
pensée de galilée dans la pensée de
galilée la terre n'est donc plus au
centre de l'univers
difficile à supporter pour l'église pour
les moines c'est même à tomber par terre
galilée lui fait confiance à sa pomme je
voyais beaucoup plus sérieux que ça et
dans la pièce il est la série blue quoi
on voit qu'il ya plusieurs idées et que
tu vas tout prix les données mais mais
mais qui a quelque chose d'obligatoire
mancini n'empêche galilée sera même
obligé de se renier sous la pression du
peuple
brecht n'a pas voulu en faire un drame
besoin peut-être finir par vivre un
temps où nous n'aurons plus à regarder
derrière nous comme des criminels pour
dire que deux et deux font quatre
sa grande trouvaille par exemple c'est
d'avoir fait de galilée un homme
sensuelle obsédé par la bouffe enfin
voilà qui est qui et qui est contraire
d'un grand savant mais un grand savant
entouré de livres mais c'est un grand
joueur avant tout un grand jouisseur et
un petit malin qui réussit finalement à
faire passer son manuscrit sous le
manteau et qui jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
s'amusera de cette évidence et pourtant
elle tourne
une image de football pour terminer 24e
journée du championnat de france et
monaco a battu nantes 2-0 buts de giuly
et de nonda et grâce à cette victoire
les monégasques prennent ce soir la
deuxième place du classement juste
derrière marseille qui avait tunisiair 2
à 0 grâce à ce but de van buyten et
cette réalisation de skitch de la tête
fin de cette édition merci de l'avoir
suivi à suivre donc la météo isabelle
martinet attention à la neige dernier
journal 12h55 jean claude renault demain
dès 6h30 et les matins dans les 4
vérités
françoise laborde recevra louis gallois
président de la sncf
on se quitte sur ces images du meilleur
sumô du monde ici
gauche pour la première fois c'est un
mongol qui accède à ce rang à sa shoryu
il a 22 ans il pèse 130 7 kilos pour 1
mètre quatre-vingt-cinq n'a pas dû
manger beaucoup de haricots verts à
demain